-The White House
released a damning memo
from President Trump's call
with the leader of Ukraine
after the House opened
a formal impeachment inquiry.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
After Democrats
announced yesterday
they would move forward
with impeachment,
the White House announced
that they would release notes
of Trump's phone call
with Ukraine's president
in which Trump pressured him to
interfere in the 2020 election
by digging up dirt on Joe Biden
and his son.
And suddenly everyone
started speculating
that maybe --
maybe the transcript
wouldn't be as bad
as we were expecting.
-I just don't understand
why you do it today
when the transcript
theoretically -- I'm not say --
could be somewhat exculpatory
of Trump.
-If the transcript
is exculpatory --
that's sort of legalese
for helpful to the president.
-Well, my first thought
is that President Trump
would not release
this transcript
if it were not exculpatory.
-Yes, he would.
Donald Trump
is literally incapable
of doing anything exculpatory.
First of all,
he would have to know
what the word
"exculpatory" means.
"Of course I know
what 'exculpatory' means.
It means you used to be
culpatory."
[ Laughter ]
And he certainly couldn't
pronounce it.
I mean, yesterday, he couldn't
even read the word "tire"
off a teleprompter.
-Americans will never fire
or tire in our effort.
-Oh, my God, he couldn't read
a one-syllable word.
And I love the irony of saying
"Americans will never tire"
while you're standing there
looking like
you just drank a bottle
of NyQuil during a gas leak.
"Americans will never tire or --
or fire."
I love that thing he does where
instead of correcting himself,
he acts like both words
were right.
Like he's reading
a Dr. Seuss book.
"Americans will never fire or
tire or get stuck in the mire,
but they'll definitely hire
a liar who perspires."
So at first some people thought
the notes from the phone call
would somehow clear Trump
of wrongdoing,
and then there was the question
of whether this supposed
transcript will even be complete
because as we all know,
White House transcripts
have been edited before.
I mean, remember,
this is the guy
who literally doctored
a hurricane map
by drawing a circle in Sharpie
to include Alabama.
There was a good chance
the supposed transcript
would come out
and the first line would be
the president of Ukraine saying,
"Thanks for being
so innocent, sir."
Then there's the fact
that actual transcripts
of Trump's words
are often incomplete
because even the world's best
stenographers
have no idea what he's saying,
like the time
the Associated Press
put out a transcript
of an interview with Trump
and there were sentences
where even the reporters
could not understand
what he was saying.
These are sentences
from the actual transcript.
"Here's part of your story.
It's going to be
a big unintelligible.
I'll tell you the other thing is
unintelligible.
We've been working on it.
Unintelligible.
Secretary Mnuchin
is a very talented person,
very smart, very successful,
unintelligible.
Let me leave a little room
just in case unintelligible."
My God, "Unintelligible" should
be his Secret Service code name.
"Unintelligible is on the move.
He said he was going
to McDernald's,
but we think he means
McDonald's."
[ Cheers and applause ]
And then, of course,
Trump himself
was going around
insisting repeatedly
that he did not pressure
the president of Ukraine
to investigate a political rival
in exchange
for hundreds of millions
of dollars in military aid.
-It was a totally appropriate
conversation.
It was actually
a beautiful conversation.
There was no quid pro quo.
There was nothing.
It was a perfect conversation.
The conversation, by the way,
was absolutely perfect.
It was a beautiful,
warm, nice conversation.
The conversation I had
with the president of Ukraine
was absolutely perfect.
The conversation I had
with the president of Ukraine
was absolutely a 10.
It was perfect.
-A 10?
Why are you talking about
a phone call
like you're creeping on women
at the beach?
"That call is a 10.
Wait until you hear the jugs
on that call."
So there you go.
The media speculated that
the call would be exculpatory,
impeachment calls
would be premature,
and Trump said it would prove
he was innocent.
They all said, "There's no way
Trump would be dumb enough
to release a transcript in which
he commits a bunch of crimes,
like asking for
a personal political favor
in exchange for hundreds
of millions of dollars
in military aid."
And then this morning, Trump
released notes from the call
in which it turns out
he was dumb enough
to commit a bunch of crimes,
like asking for
a personal political favor
in exchange for hundreds
of millions of dollars
in military aide.
-Here's what the president said.
"There's a lot of talk
about Biden's son,
that Biden stopped
the prosecution,
and a lot of people want
to find out about that,
so whatever you can do with the
Attorney General would be great.
Biden went around bragging
that he stopped the prosecution.
So if you can look into it,
it sounds horrible to me."
-The first investigation
that the president brings up
with the president of Ukraine --
This is immediately following
the Ukrainian president's
mention of military aid
and how he wants to continue
with military aid
from the United States,
which we know at this point,
a large portion of which
had been suspended.
Here's what the president says
in response
to that conversation.
"I would like to ask you
to do us a favor, though,
because our country
has been through a lot.
Ukraine knows a lot about it."
-In an official call with the
president of another country,
he literally brought up
Joe Biden, Rudy Giuliani,
and said the words "I would
like you to do us a favor."
It doesn't get more obvious
than that.
It actually would have
been better for Trump
if the whole transcript had
just said "unintelligible."
At when Trump asks
for the favor,
it wasn't just
an innocent request.
As this call was happening,
Trump was holding up hundreds
of millions of dollars
in military aid to Ukraine
that Ukraine desperately wanted
from the U.S.
In fact, Trump specifically
brought up the Biden stuff
right after
the Ukrainian president
brought up that military aid.
In the memo,
the Ukrainian president said,
"I would also like to thank you
for your great support
in the area of defense."
And then the very next sentence
out of Trump's mouth was,
"I would like you
to do us a favor, though."
That is an obvious quid pro quo.
The only way
it's not a quid pro quo
is that when it comes
to committing crimes,
Trump is definitely not a pro.
He's an idiot.
It's more like a quid idiot quo.
He literally said, "I'd like you
to do us a favor."
He might as well have been
having this meeting
at his daughter's wedding
while petting a cat.
Or if not a cat,
one of his other pets.
[ Laughter ]
Let's remember --
Let's remember Rudy Giuliani
was a private citizen,
the president's personal lawyer,
who was on a fishing expedition
to concoct a fake scandal
and get Ukraine
to manufacture dirt
on a political opponent,
Joe Biden.
The fact that his name came up
on this call even once
is insane,
but look how many times
Trump mentioned Rudy.
"Mr. Giuliani's
a highly respected man.
He was the mayor
of New York City, great mayor.
And I would like him
to call you.
I will ask him to call you,
along with the Attorney General.
Rudy very much knows
what's happening
and he's a very capable guy."
But he's not.
He does not know
what's happening
and he is definitely
not a capable guy.
For one thing,
any time he does a interview,
he looks like a guy
in a haunted house
after a zombie just popped out
of the bushes.
[ Laughter ]
In fact, Rudy has spent
the last few days
spitting out live
on national television.
First he tried out
some prop comedy
by showing everyone his phone
in a Fox interview
and then showing up to another
Fox interview reading a book.
Why?
Why's he doing prop comedy now.
"Here's a phone.
Here's a book.
And here's one of my puppets.
He's actually my brother."
Also, I can assure you, Rudy
is not a highly respected man.
In fact,
just to give you an idea
of how little he's respected
on Capitol Hill,
Politico reported today that,
and this is real,
"At the House Democratic meeting
this morning,
Rudy Giuliani was the butt
of a joke.
Congressman Hakeem Jeffries
showed a Seth Meyers sizzle reel
of Giuliani's recent
cable appearances.
The room erupted in laughter."
That's right,
as House Democrats --
[ Cheers and applause ]
As they were meeting
to discuss impeaching the
president of the United States,
they were watching a sizzle
reel of our Rudy Giuliani jokes.
Does that mean I could get
called as an official witness
in the impeachment?
Oh, my God
[ Cheers and applause ]
I mean, I already have
my testimony prepared.
"Yes, Mr. Chairman,
while I do not have any insights
into Mr. Giuliani's
conversations with Ukraine,
I can confirm that he does,
in fact,
look like he accidentally
stuck his [bleep]
in an electrical socket."
[ Laughter ]
"Yes, you heard me right."
So you got the president
dangling a quid pro quo
asking for a political favor
and repeatedly prodding
a foreign leader
to speak with
his personal lawyer
and manufacture a baseless smear
of a political opponent.
Just what we can see
in this memo alone
is impeachable behavior,
let alone what's in the full
whistle-blower complaint.
I mean, can you imagine how bad
that full whistle-blower
report is?
What else could it possibly say?
"After the call, Mr. Trump then
stood up, tripped on his tie,
fell headfirst into a garbage
can, got up, ran into a wall,
knocked himself unconscious,
woke up, and screamed,
'Where am I,
and who [bleep] my pants?'"
[ Laughter, applause ]
Today...
Today Trump actually met
with the president of Ukraine
on the sidelines
of the United Nations
and claimed he hadn't
pressured him
while also insisting all he
cared about was corruption.
-You know what?
There was no pressure.
And, by the way, you know
there was no pressure.
All you have to do is see it,
what went on on the call.
-Would you like
President Zelensky
to do more on Joe Biden
and the investigation?
-No, I want him to do
whatever he can
but whatever he can do
in terms of corruption
because the corruption
is massive.
-Oh, you want him to do
something with corruption?
Okay, well, he's sitting
right next to you.
Did he bring his handcuffs?
'Cause when it comes
to stopping corruption,
one thing's for sure.
The president of Ukraine
will never...
-Fire or tire.
-Now, one big question looming
over the impeachment debate
has always been
the political impact.
How would it affect Trump's
chances of getting reelected?
Would it cut into his chances,
or would it solidify his base?
Some Democrats have been scared
that impeachment
would somehow be good for him
or play into his hands.
We have to drop this idea
that Trump is playing
three-dimensional chess.
He's more like a guy
who ate a chess piece,
is now choking on it,
and instead of gesturing
for the Heimlich maneuver,
eats another chess piece
to dislodge the first one.
In fact, Trump himself
has made this argument,
that he wants to be impeached
because it would somehow be good
for him politically.
In fact, he repeated that claim
again yesterday.
-The country's doing the best
it's ever done.
And I just heard that
she'd like to impeach.
Our country's doing
the best it's ever done.
They're going to lose
the election,
and they figure
this is a thing to do.
This never happened where
we're in the election.
And, I mean, if she does that,
they all say that's a positive
for me from the election.
You could also say,
"Who needs it?
It's bad for the country."
-Of course, his first priority
is, "It's good for me."
And then he throws in
as an afterthought,
"Also, it's bad
for the country."
He's like an athlete
who bet against his own team.
"Yes, the Patriots
scored a touchdown!
I mean, damn, let's go, Jets."
The reality is that
if we finally have
a real formal impeachment
process with hearings and votes,
we'll all get to see
actual evidence
of Trump's serial corruption
and lawbreaking
live on national television
every single day.
And that's a huge deal.
Now, just before
we taped this show,
Trump held another
of his signature
off-the-rails press conferences
where he once again lost his
mind on national television.
First he started out by claiming
the whistle-blower
who reported on his conversation
with the president of Ukraine
didn't have what he called
first-class information,
although it was hard to follow
what he was saying.
-The so-called whistle-blower,
the one that didn't have
any first-class or first-rate
or second-tier information,
from what I understand.
You'll have to figure that out
for yourself.
-Firsthand!
He didn't have any
firsthand information!
[ Cheers and applause ]
"First-rate, first-class.
Didn't have any
first-base information.
The common phrase,
first-base information."
I mean, why does he make us
try to figure out
what the hell
he's trying to say?
"You'll have to figure out
what I'm --
I'll say words, then you guys
put them into sentences."
[ Laughter ]
Then Trump complained
that because everyone
was talking about Ukraine
and impeachment,
no one was covering
how hard he was working
during his meetings
with foreign leaders.
-The sad thing about this hoax
is that we work so hard
with all of these countries.
And, I mean, really hard.
I've been up from early in the
morning to late in the evening
and meeting with
different countries,
all for the good of our country,
and the press doesn't even cover
all of this.
-Early in the mornings
and late in --
So you mean a workday.
You had a workday.
"We start in the morning.
And then we stop for lunch.
It's called a lunch break.
First I've heard of it.
Then we have meetings again
at night.
I'm working like eight,
nine hours a day."
[ Laughter ]
Trump wants us all
to be impressed
by how hard the job is.
But we knew it was hard.
You're like the only one
who was like,
"Presidents work mornings?"
What we saw in today's memo
alone is impeachable behavior,
and Trump and his lawyer
keep going on TV
and confessing to more crimes.
When it comes to corruption
and lawlessness,
what we saw today was...
-Absolutely a 10.
It was perfect.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]